-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to the "Tonight Show"!
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
today marks one full year
in office for President Biden.
It's been a challenging a year.
When asked what he's learned,
Biden said,
"Being vice president
was a hell of a lot more fun."
[ Laughter ]
A year ago, Biden pledged
to address COVID, the economy,
climate change,
and racial injustice.
And, good news, after 12 months
of tireless effort,
we're all getting
three free masks.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
This is nice.
Biden's inaugural committee
marked his anniversary
by releasing a video
touting America's recovery,
narrated by Tom Hanks.
Hanks wasn't the first choice,
but staffers had to explain
to Biden that Gary Cooper
died 60 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, yesterday, in his
two-hour press conference,
Biden --
two-hour press conference?
[ Laughter ]
Biden covered a lot
and said the U.S.
might not do anything
if Russia's invasion of Ukraine
is only minor.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
One of his few slip-ups.
And it's a big deal,
'cause at Biden's age, any slip
could be a catastrophe.
You know...
[ Laughter ]
What is a minor invasion?
A soldier sticks
one foot in Ukraine?
He's like, "Just kidding!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, today, Biden tried
to clear things up by saying
any Russian invasion
would be met
with severe economic response.
Biden was like,
"Try me, tough guy,
and I'll turn your economy
into ours."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, over time, Biden will hit
Putin with economic penalties.
In other words, Biden is using
the same strategy as Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
"It's only another dollar.
Can't stop now."
[ Laughter ]
During the press conference,
Biden also said
that Kamala Harris would be his
running mate again in 2024.
Then he mentioned
they're already working
on potential campaign slogans
for their re-election.
Take a look at these.
First up, there's...
[ Laughter ]
Next, they have...
And, finally, there's...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Pretty good.
Some business news --
today, Amazon announced
that this year,
it's opening its own
clothing store,
called Amazon Style.
Though, I'm not sure
Amazon Style is the best option
when your founder
dresses like this.
But I don't know. Maybe I'm...
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Amazon is focusing on clothing.
Even crazier,
Abercrombie & Fitch
is going to start
launching people into space.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that...
Well, this is fun.
I saw that Queen Elizabeth
is getting into
the condiment business.
That's right,
she's releasing her own
royal estate tomato sauce.
Yeah, the Queen says
tomato sauce is just like
her mother's servant
used to make.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Last week, Prince Andrew
was stripped
of his royal status,
and now his official Twitter
and YouTube accounts
have been deleted.
The Queen was like,
"No Twitter, no YouTube.
Now go to your castle."
[ Laughter ]
I saw that the CEO of crypto.com
just confirmed that it suffered
a security breach, and hundreds
of accounts were hacked.
That's terrible.
I mean, if you can't trust
a website called crypto.com...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard that police
in Canada are looking for a man
who allegedly stole
an $8,000 guitar
by hiding it in his pants.
[ Laughter ]
The first giveaway?
Guitar-shaped pants.
[ Laughter ]
When he was approached
by security, he was like,
"Oh, I walked in with
this guitar in my pants."
[ Laughter ]
The guy was easy to spot.
He was the one
walking away
from the store like...
[ Guitar strumming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Strumming continues ]
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a home listing
in Wisconsin has gone viral
because of the house's
unusual bathroom setup.
Take a look at this.
It's real.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-It's weird when you knock
on the door and three people
are like, "Occupied!"
[ Laughter ]
♪ Occupied ♪
-♪ Occupied ♪
-We have a great show!
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What a great show
we have for you tonight.
He stars in the new series
"MacGruber,"
which is streaming now
on Peacock,
and he's hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with musical guest Maneskin.
Will Forte is here!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Forte!
Plus, she is amazing.
From the HBO series
"The White Lotus" --
boy, that was a home run --
Jennifer Coolidge is here.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And his new album, "DS4Ever,"
is number one
on the Billboard 200
albums chart right now.
We got music from Gunna!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"DS4Ever."
First of all, I want to say
a quick happy birthday
to our pal Questlove.
It's his, uh...
-Aww!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
-Happy birthday, bud!
-Thank you.
-So much going on.
A lot to talk about.
I mean,
it's Questlove's birthday.
Today is Joe Biden's one-year
anniversary as president.
This is actually nice.
A lot of people
reached out
to congratulate Biden.
-Really?
-Yeah, check out
some of the text messages
he got.
For instance,
Kamala Harris wrote,
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-Isn't that nice?
-That's sweet.
She cares.
-Yeah.
And former president
Obama wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Nice again.
-Well...
-Next up, Joe Manchin wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on!
That's a good one.
-"As much as I'd like to --
I just can't do it."
-Can't do it.
-No.
-Then, Tom Brady wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, Bernie sanders wrote...
And then,
Donald Trump wrote...
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally,
Prince Andrew wrote...
Well, it's nice to hear
from everybody.